you guys have heard of Felix the Cat yes
of course of course you know Felix the
Cat yeah no Ollie the cat I know your
cat that is only yes that is the cat
that Marion and I share but let's talk
about fistopher okay look at this sad
photo of fistopher from New Jersey's
Homeward Bound pet adoption I don't mean
laughs pet adoption center yes Nate a
lot of people yes you do need to laugh
about things what is up with this little
kitty cat look at that little face
workers who are there at the shelter
said that he seemed quote out of sorts
the shelter posted Christopher's story
on pepper fish defer his name is
Christopher they've posted a story on
Pet Finder hoping to find him a forever
home okay they called him sweet and easy
going and they even added that
Christopher is a big cheeky boy wouldn't
you love rubbing up on those big shoes
how do you say it again wouldn't you
love me look a little fist of her there
the listing went viral and then on
Thanksgiving the shelter posted some
good news Christopher has left the
building it said it had gotten hundreds
of inquiries some people had even formed
a line outside for you little fistafer
for you people were lining up to adopt
you turns out a young couple from
Maryland they drove hours to the shelter
just to be the lucky ones who got to
take fist of her home their names are
okay yeah I want to give Laura fultz and
her partner Tanner Callahan the shout
out because they saw that photo
Christopher and never judge a book or a
kitty cat by its cover kitties generally
look grumpy but they have so much love
to give and Christopher has a forever
home now no they always seem a little
aloof to me I'm not knocking cats
want love on their terms
agency in life just like you you want
love on you that's exactly right meow
okay yeah we know you can get frisky
every now and then all right
congratulations Christopher yes that's
right